I don't think in history that's always
been a bad thing because typically in
exchange for this they would get Purity
they would get you they would get kids
you know 200 years ago each woman had
seven children yet in modern times I
don't even think we have three kids no
we're not even having enough kids to
replace the parents and then a third a
third child and you know we're getting
married around I I think it's in some
countries it's literally at 35 like I
was in Ireland last year and I think 34
35 was the average marriage date and
this is the guys this is the society
we're in so
you know and and I realized too that I
think we have a society uh basically
Kings and lonely men because most
of the women are sleeping with the top
ten twenty percent of men and the bottom
80 percent of men are just lonely